anything no look man I know you just had
a really bad brain injury and you can't
remember anything but this is our old
bar we used to come here once a week so
tonight let's just try to have a fun
time and hopefully you could just jog
your memory and you can get back to
being the old you okay that sounds good
man hey it's Jeff right yeah Jeff this
is the bar wow you don't remember you
would always buy two shots of tequila
for us I would my best friend doesn't
remember me well no no I do I do
um yeah we'll take two shots up to here
top-shelf tequila we would always do
top-shelf because we're top-shelf
friends and there's our favorite song
that you won't remember I wish I could
buy right now but I'm a little strapped
for cash
yeah you know when you're in your coma I
was paying for your rent and it's your
insurance and your car payment and I was
taking your girlfriend out she's just
been a mess you know anything to
distract her you know a little dinner
here a little movie there a little
dancing it just it all adds up oh well
how much I owe you no no man we're
friends you know owe me anything
I mean seriously it was two thousand
eight hundred and seventy seven dollars
no let me let me pay you about as well
please really is here given what I do I
guess anything the girls check me out
you know you don't you don't like girls
anymore remember where yeah he told me
like right before the accident that
you're just kind of done
yeah my girlfriend you said that you
were gonna break up with her
you just haven't told her yet yeah so
you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna go
over there and just talk to her probably
get her number because I don't want you
going in there and just getting even
more confused you know do this for you
so we over there and then you can you
talk to that guy that guy's your type
right Justin Justin it's me Jeff your
best friend Jeff like there was a crazy
guy that kidnap you from the hospital
you know what my real best friend Jeff
wore me you come here trying to
impersonate him yeah disgusting whoa
what was that just some guy trying to
take advantage of me oh hey ready for me
to buy that in your car well you did
promise it to me before your injury
okay so I'll coming back to me